this is my favorite question to ask
people do you have any fetishes
[Laughter]
because usually when i think of
preachers i think of like super pricey
super like perfect i have lots of
relationships uh through my congregation
through my work with
women and men young people who were in
the system and so i'm going to ask you a
question
make an assumption about me
i would say
as a female pastor
you would probably be very judgy
really
i think sometimes women in the church
think we have to be
a certain kind of prissy good something
i'm not gonna wear makeup i'm gonna
act like i've never had sex i'm gonna
you know i have to stuff down my woman
stuff
so people take me seriously what's your
judgment about me
that you've been hurt by people like me
that's a very accurate assumption yeah
yeah i actually went viral for it when i
came out with my story the church
shunned me literally the church shunned
i was disrespected i was taught every
jedi from here the next week it was like
i went in there
really just to meet someone and walked
out next thing you know empowering a
group full of women and basically
shutting down a women's
panel at the prophetic college it was
pretty cool
what do you know about my current
profession
what do you know about us
i i'm gonna be embarrassed right here
say your daughter comes up to you and
it's like mom i'm a dominatrix what
would you think she's doing oh i think
she has a
a closet full of beautiful tools and
toys
uh some of which i might enjoy my own
self uh but like um i'm going red i'm
going spandex i'm going pointy breast
gear she'd be like hey bob
bob
take your pants off get on that bed damn
it and give them a little
butt touch
there's no sex involved in anything that
i do bdsm is really all about fetish
i've had clients who have paid me to
chew bubble gum for a couple hours i
have clients who have paid me to brush
their teeth it could be anything from
you have a fetish of you want to give me
all your money would you be giving that
money back to them in any kind of
transaction girl no okay i don't think
so i work for my dollars one thing i've
learned about pastors is that pastors
are like they do everything they go from
being the counselor the teacher the
psychologists
do we have fetishes
yes yes
i learned that the closer you are to god
the more sexual you are i think that's
right well it was actually a pastor that
got me into bdsm oh is that right ooh do
you want to tell that story well i'll
just say he was just a very
very uh kinky little preacher man
we'll just put it like that so
yeah do you think religion causes more
conflict than it solves
i i do
i mean i don't think it has to so i'm
not saying all religion but i'm saying
religion historically has caused more
conflict than it solved i don't think
religion by itself
andrea is a weapon but i think people
weaponize religion
and that's tragic
religion literally means to bind
together
and i gotta say i walked away from
church too
i had a car accident when i was
22
and i almost died
and andrea i was convinced i was
convinced
that the car accident was god's
punishment
for you not going to church no for me
having sex with my fiance two weeks
before i got married just that face that
you made that's exactly where i was
years of
don't have sex don't have sex numbers i
have six number six and i just thought
oh wow i really failed god right there
and that's why this car is flipping over
in the qew and i'm almost dying now
that's just some bs right there theology
and that kind of theology kills and i
don't do that kind of theology
what is a dream you've let go of
it might cry
i come from the system
um growing up in foster care
i couldn't you know go to college and
like it sucks you know they're like i
wanted to be a lawyer couldn't because
i didn't have the resources i didn't
have
the things that most kids do and that
kids take like for granted and then to
be a dominatrix
who was a foster kid people already look
at me like she was a posh kid so
obviously she was troublesome you know
there's a stigma around us as well
and then to get into bdsm there's just
this huge stigma but i love to break it
every time so
i am so
moved by your badassery to get the life
you wanted yeah i worked really hard you
did
could you ever see yourself doing my
profession absolutely why not why not
absolutely not absolutely not no the
board would fire me day one because you
were so like honestly stayed forward and
you saw well
i'd like to disrupt things that do not
you know sit well with me so they would
day one they'd be like ma'am
it was nice
but you gotta go you gotta go you gotta
go you just gotta come to church we
would all be a room full of sinners it
would be the worst church ever
or it could be the best church ever
i think if i wasn't at my church i
wouldn't be a pastor
no no could you do my job
i think maybe so i could i think you
honestly i think you make a great
dominance i'm just trying to tell a
sister the truth
what is it
this is a good one is it good
this is my favorite question to ask
people okay do you have any fetishes oh
don't give us a politically correct
answer we want to dig deep
i have a fetish for
orgasm until you just can't do it again
yep what about you i have a fetish for
cologne a
foot fetish in a sense but i have a solo
mail fetish
we'll let minds wonder where that goes
i know some people who have fetishes for
my breasts
i'll say that
they're cute
was your initial assumption about me
correct
[Music]
yeah
yeah but i walked by your room
and i thought i saw some light that was
going to come popping out in this
conversation and it did so i would say
yeah okay yeah i would say no yeah i
would say no i was like
she's got the robe on
she dylan's sister act coming in she's
about to come
look at me with the ruler
she's going to bend me over and spank me
now but i would say no actually no i
actually did think you know because my
experience with women in the church
have not always been
good but i'm glad that we did this
because now
i can say i was wrong
you're so much prettier when i was a
young person i was always swirling this
color palette for me down here it was
like you know when i came in it was like
i'm a scarlet letter a but then i felt
more at home and put it there oh that's
very good
in my experience if you listen to
someone's story you are less than six
degrees of separation from something
where you are very much alike
she almost had me halfway ready to go to
church but i won't